[Music]
[Applause]
let me bring in
chris sims pro football talk live
co-host on peacock nbc sunday night
football analyst
who took the biggest hit over the
weekend out of that group well
okay i'm not gonna i mean michigan we
knew michigan was michigan i mean
i don't know that's not that big against
indiana
well i don't know i don't know if
they're that special michigan this year
so you're right that was bad because
it's maybe
indiana i'm not gonna throw them in the
class clemson
hey that hurt but i mean if anybody puts
them outside of the top four
or national championship contention
they're crazy without the best player in
college football playing
seahawks uh i don't know the same old
seahawks they have no defense and they
rely on russell wilson every play i
think the most concerning to me would be
the bucks and how they played and how
that looked overall last night dan
why did it get out of hand so quickly um
i think that
the thing just you know for to keep it
simple
i mean it looked like the new orleans
saints went out there
pissed off for lack of a better phrase
we're a team we're battle tested we've
been in these positions before
you guys are the new kids on the block
and you're reading all your press
clippings
and it's like new orleans got in their
face from the get-go on the offense and
defensive side of the ball
and just controlled the line of
scrimmage now and offensively
they just picked it apart with breeze
and short passing game that's kind of
how they do it at times
but defensively i think that was the
shock i mean
people at the line of scrimmage in your
face coverage
and not being able to get any separation
from the tampa bay receivers
and then never even really trying to
establish a run game i mean go back and
look at the play
it was like they thought oh it's gronk
it's brown it's evans it's good one you
can't match up with us we're too good
and it kind of just backfired in their
face obviously yeah i wondered about the
game plan there
and yeah right the addition to antonio
brown
what did you make of that well he looked
good i mean i i can't get over how damn
good the guy
is without playing football for so long
i mean he's he
he will work his way into having a
spot in that offense now him and brady
were off sync on that one interception
you know where that's about reading the
coverage the guy's too far off you hook
it up if the guy's close to you you go
deep they'll figure that out i'm not
concerned necessarily about that
the one thing i just look at the bucks
is and where i've always been so excited
about them
is their versatility on offense and it's
like last night they fell
into the trap of like oh we got weapons
so let's get in the shotgun and throw it
every play
but if you really go back and look at
their year they've been at their best
when they have a little balance and they
run the ball
and then brady has the play-action pass
to gronk over the middle in those things
and uh last night it looks like they got
away with it and just got a little too
obsessed with the the wide receiver
position
if you had to pick right now and i said
the saints buccaneers packers
seahawks who's going to the super bowl
or other in the nfc
no i think i think that's the teams that
really come to mind right off the bat i
think those are the four main football
teams really until the last two weeks i
would have been saying the buccaneers
you know it's two weeks in a row where i
know they beat the giants but you know i
know that wasn't a good look last week
and they got
physically kind of pushed around by new
york too
so right now and i can't believe i'm
really saying this but the way they won
last night
i mean it's hard not to pick the saints
with you know
that team that coach the defense i've
been saying this a lot dan the defense
has been good all year
it's like they let three or four plays
every game they dominate they dominate
they dominate
and then they let up a big pass player
two big pass pays
it's been issues like that and you know
if they can execute like that on offense
and
not let up those big plays on defense
then i am going to pick the saints
steelers are undefeated but yeah they've
won their last three by three
four and five points and the losing team
had a chance to win the game in the
final minute here
yeah like last lackluster as it gets i
mean disappointing by the steelers
defense that they let the cowboys run
the ball
on them like that kind of controlled
them it's two weeks in a row the
steelers defense has been pushed around
a little bit too
you know but i think the other thing
that you know
offensively the steelers are just not a
machine yet either
you know i expect their defense to still
play at a high level i
again it's human nature you know i think
they fell in the trap yesterday hey
we beat the ravens we're the best team
in football
the cowboys who's this playing
quarterback i've never even heard of
them we're gonna run them over
they fell into that trap and dallas is
desperate and fighting for their lives
over there
um but the offensive thing is is the
thing that i look at with pittsburgh
i do be just because dan there's no run
game
it's always like we got to figure out
how to finagle a pass game on a weekly
basis and a lot of the times they figure
out the correct formula eventually but
it's not pretty and it's going to come
back to bite them in the butt at some
point
what about the chiefs they yeah they can
look
incredible uh one series and then all of
a sudden you're going
carolina's got a chance to win this game
in kansas city
like um you know i i think another case
of a team
that's maybe a little asleep taking it
for granted
not used to being hey the bullseye's on
your back every week kansas city you're
the greatest show in town everybody
wants to see it kids are tuning in to
watch patrick mahomes the chiefs the
super bowl champs all those things
i think that you know there's there's no
you can't let down when you're the team
in that position
let alone sloppiness at times i mean hey
i know they went for the fake punt the
carolina panthers that was a big moment
chris jones had a few bad penalties on
third downs
things like that to where there's so
many times during the game
dan and i know you watched where you
just go they're about to put them away
what they did that they're about to put
them away why why would they do that
you know there's just too much of that
at times i don't lose faith in them
though
i do think they're one of those teams
that kind of just rises to the challenge
has great belief and there's just too
many good playmakers on that team for me
to think much less of them
pro football talk live co-host on
peacock chris sims nbc sunday night
football analyst
i was watching the cowboys and i don't i
don't know how a cowboy fan will feel
about this
i came away going they cared
like they played like they cared is it
that simple that
it's hard to explain yeah given every
you know all the odds and the obstacles
and you're putting in a quarterback who
hadn't played
uh and you're going against the steelers
yeah no i think there's something to say
about that
well we saw the two weeks before that we
weren't sure if they care the two weeks
i'll say this the last two weeks they
showed they cared the eagle game
hey they did they did some good things i
think you would agree they had a
quarterback that was
really really raw and they they just
didn't take advantage of the
opportunities they had but at least they
showed fight
and yes yesterday they did there's no
doubt about that i mean that was
something
i think we were all a little concerned
about with the cowboys even when dak
prescott was healthy there was moments
where you just go
where's the edge the attitude the
physicality of this football team
and the last two weeks with some of the
cool things they've done in the run game
and things like that to give them a
little edge i think has
made them a little bit tougher and they
are answering the bell and i'll give
mike mccarthy credit there
they're not a real good football team
but at least they're they're fighting
uh two against kyler was great what what
it really was it was a lot of fun
it was i mean first off kyla murray is
unbelievable he's just a game changer
with what he does i mean his big arm
and his ability to run and when they
dial up a few design
quarterback runs for him i mean he's
special i mean he's got
who who wins in a race between him and
lamar jackson who do you think wins in a
race between those two
i think kyler is quicker right i don't
know
it depends on how long the race is yeah
i think you're right
right that lamar would probably catch
him if they went past 60 yards but
kyler's quick man oh my gosh i mean he's
got
you know i always say the flurry he's
got three rockets up his butt i've never
seen anybody accelerate like that it's
unreal
not it really is not literally not
literally
it might be uncomfortable but yeah that
was a fun game they
you know two is kind of slide there were
a couple of moments where
him of all quarterbacks i mean kyler's
slides
that baseball mentality i don't
understand it with you quarterbacks that
you know you're going to take on we had
josh allen on two weeks ago
and i said you got a slide he goes yeah
i know but i want to run i go no
you have to preserve your i don't care
who you are there's somebody bigger than
you
and faster than you yes
it's part of life and football i mean if
you want to be
tom brady or drew brees right and have a
long career
look at what they have done they don't
let people kill them
they never let the defense get off that
way they're like oh look it i got them
flushed that way
and their greatest importance to their
team is their availability they know
that
and yes some of these young quarterbacks
because they it's this new age where
they can
run and make plays with their legs
they're wired a little differently but
they are still football players tua
you're right
it was one of the biggest concerns for
him coming out of alabama was sometimes
his awkwardness with people around him
i would like him to be careful but man
good for him yesterday
like you left-handed quarterbacks are
putting everything you
possibly can into your throws two it
looks like he's
the energy he's throwing it 80 yards
and he's only throwing it 16. well this
is he doesn't have a very strong arm
this is something that i argued with a
lot of people through the draft and this
is where
you know again he's doing well but
they're calling plays that fit
just him right now and how long will
they be able to do it we'll see but you
saw the game enough yesterday right
it was bootlegs oh here's a dump or or a
10-yard crosser
oh here's a screen and then oh it's
one-on-one on the outside we'll just
throw a little fade go ball right up
there i mean that's basically what their
game
plan was and my big thing about picking
them apart
in the college draft a little bit was
just that
what you're kind of talking about nfl
type throws people around you
you can't get your whole body and give
it the whole like 100 percent effort
are you still going to be able to make a
throw with people around you in a
20-yard income or anything like that
when that does happen i don't know we'll
see but either way he's gritty
i love his charisma and the dolphins you
see
why they had to make the switch they
made the switch not only because they
want to want him to play and get the
experience
but they knew they were good and had a
chance to go on a run here
and they were in danger of putting
themselves in why would we give up on
ryan fitzpatrick we're nine and three
we're doing great
and i think they realized that might
have been an issue and that's why they
pulled the trigger as far as getting two
in there dan any chance the jets screw
things up and win tonight
i don't think so uh i do think it'll be
ugly
but you know the jets offense is not
good enough to take
advantage of the weakness of the
patriots which is their run defense so i
don't think that's a great like
advantage jets
i don't think they're gonna be able to
throw the ball jets defense is a pain in
the butt
as we know but it's not real talented
and i think eventually that patriots
offense can run the ball on just about
anybody
and they're just a little bit more
talented to where i think they win like
a 24
16 you know 23 14 type of game dan
what are you thinking when you throw an
interception or
as as a quarterback and then you may
have to tackle somebody philip rivers
phillip rivers didn't didn't have a good
day yesterday
um you know peyton would famously just
sort of fall down and
you know like and and i get that right
andrew luck wanted to one of the hardest
hits i've ever seen in college football
was delivered by andrew luck in a game
where he threw an interception
and he closed on this guy and just
annihilated him
yeah well i mean he's built like a
linebacker back in his college days so
he had a different mindset than me i
know that for sure
all right i mean my my to answer the
first part of the question when you
threw it in
when you throw an interception you throw
it you see it
and you just i can't believe that i
can't believe he intercepted it i can't
believe i threw it
then he starts to run around and you
start as a quarterback at least i did i
was like
come on somebody make the tackle
somebody make the tower and you're
really hoping somebody will make the
tackle
and you're just staying alive just to
hope you don't have to do it
and of course that time is going to come
where you're going to have to at one
point i've made a few i think in my nfl
career but i can't
pull over check and see if chris sims
has any
tackles correct through some
interceptions you know that 18
18 career picks no tackles that's being
smart protecting the brand
no you know what i did too i think i got
two tackles actually on
fumbles uh by like the
by the running back where he fumbled and
now i'm there
and like i believe it was frosty rucker
back in the day the carolina panthers he
picked up a fumble from cadillac
williams
and he was running right at me and i was
like i don't know what to do
i just know i'm not gonna win this so i
just got low and i let him run
over me and i stuck up my hands and i
just got he'll trip he'll fall down
and he did
good to check in with you chris always
great to talk to you thank you
thank you see be good guys see everybody
that's chris sims pro football talk live
co-host on peacock nbc sunday night
football
analyst